prende tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vigente ci siano sul gioco
chiamato di xfactor
la scelta della lingua è bellissimo c'è
la sceglie tra inglese piccini keyek
biografia ma [ __ ] che cazzo a the
sims e questo è quello giusto jet
privato camicie eccolo qui ce l'abbiamo
già vi fei possiamo iniziare ragazzi
sono prontissimo i sei ragazzi possiamo
cominciare col nostro bellissimo
personaggio uscito da c'è veramente su
the sims l'avrei fatto molto meglio è la
nostra di membro io sono felice ma
grazie che permette deve uscire di qua
sono già partiti qualche figo ragazzi
non so bene che cosa cazzo ci possa
trovare in questo gioco però andiamo
avanza e so che è una specie di horror
credo perché non credo sia un gioco di
tipo dei teletubbies
allo stesso tempo dovrebbe essere
alquanto figo perché sembra veramente
figo vederlo così però a me si può
sparare in questo gioco qua o prendo le
cose creux portato ragazzi chi è che ha
fatto quel verso di prima che non ho
mica capito ma salve ho detto sì quello
che stava in macelleria l'altro giorno
armando armando ascoltami e accelera
roba qua non so che cosa ti abbia ucciso
armando però non hai una bella cera vai
a casa dalla mamma che è meglio mi fate
capire se si può andare di qua
perfezioni condotti ascoltate lega non
dobbiamo fare la fine di armando non
seguite l'esempio di armando nel caso vi
troviate in una navicella spaziale
sperduta perché credo che sia navicella
spaziale questa credo di sì poi non so
se qualcuno ha percosso starnutito a
terra è un ep mille che si è sciolto
porca la [ __ ] ho preso la scala e va
beh ma di quello che ce la sto ste cazzo
ne so io a posto perfetto e nel mentre
gli altri troppo danno infilare arca
pranzi però non c'è nessuno quindi va
bene così
armando sei sempre tu arma hanno questo
braccio di armando veda il pezzo per
pezzo
e qui lo posso sentire lo posso sentire
qui che si può andare avanti così con i
tre secondi spunta un gesù a caso a chi
è ma che cosa era stavo scherzando
quando ho detto che pensavo ci fosse
cioè credevo non mi spuntasse davanti
come prima questa volta in quella serie
ragazzi questa volta quella serbo io
sono rinchiuso in questa navicella
spaziale o quello che sembra questo
tizio bello e l'obiettivo sarebbe quello
di uscire c'è un luogo dove posso
arrivare sano e salvo devo fare la fine
di armando ogni sacrosanta volta di qua
9 chiedo perché non si sa mai
il braccio lega
piano piano piano piano piano piano
piano ricordo cazzo se lo chantecler c'è
perché cielo suntech le ragazze aiuto la
carta igienica formato gigante per
pulirsi il culo quando ci si carica
addosso non è male sul muro a fiori mi
ricorda quello di mia nonna non so
perché c'è nessuno sono fa vj sono un
bravo ragazzo carino delle impronte o
mio dio ha calpestato le prime a una
bella fetta sa numero 45 mi dicono lo
ska tenati un camino
questo è il pene di armando che lo
lasciamo qui tutta la vacca che ho
beccato beccato l'ania tranquille poste
la trappola che sta si sta eccitando
perché mi sta toccando c'è un [ __ ]
che si aggira tra le tubature tipo il
basilisco di harry potter perché devo
sentire dei rumori oliva
[Musica]
ok ok bene milano convintissimo di star
tranquillo nelle tubature c'è poco
convinto scansa le mani di armando lui
lido pervertito ecco perché ecco perché
bisogna mettere la crema solare ad haga
la crema solare quando ti spiaggia
ricordatevi che fa caldo ok la mia
miseria vista mi ha visto mi ha visto
invece porca [ __ ] tanto non puoi
scendere può scendere
forse anatraia via via via via via via
via via via via via via via via via via
via
ma è bello questo gioco bello mi piace
molto cioè non so proprio come ho fatto
a dimenticarmi di giocarlo prima
ciao armando consigliatemi sempre giochi
così belli perché mi piace giocare a
questi giochi belli
grazie ma poi non ho capito perché io
entravo lecco sono entrato nel condotto
perché l'ho visto fuori però era anche
nel condotto ce ne sono due o sono
stronzi
queste sono commerce siccome le orme
vanno direttamente qua sotto io eviterei
di andare lì sotto andiamo da un'altra
parte
no no no no no no no no no no li happy
meal dei primi la terra da ci sono scuse
mi sotto la banca non sotto la panca la
capra campri io lo odio questo cazzo di
gioco ve lo sto dicendo ragazze passo
sul letto fra slam force forse mi salvo
poi io sento ce l'ho fatta vai veloce
sotto
beh allora sì stronzo sinistro niente
lega non c'è stato verso ho provato però
ci ho provato e col cazzo ragazzi sono
troppo degli gnocchi quelli visto gioco
sono veramente belli gesù loro sono in
due sono invece sono morto però sono in
due
questo l'ho capito uno è molto più bello
dell'altro molto di più la cosa più
triste che io quando sono nei condotti
in un gioco horror e la prima cosa che
penso è che sono sicuro che la cosa è
molto triste
ok lo chantecler ragazzi la risposta a
tutto perché non lo fanno prendere
[Musica]
che bello ecco si può chiudere la porta
e voglio guardare fuori che cos'è ma
dove minchia siamo e stava andando a
castrocaro terme come cazzo ci son
finito qua avevo detto a mia madre che
non sapevo prendere il treno cazzo lo
sapevo io accuso triste di questo gioco
lega che c'è un silenzio della madonna
che quando ci spuntano davanti ti
sputano che non te ne accorgi succede
che proprio tts lo del cervello amici
miei per le mestruazioni esiste locchi
credo che si usi quello non so
orsacchiotti a no no no no no no no no
scherzavo mamma posso mettermi nel letto
che tanto e pulito faccio un kit medico
non unica visto si apre cazzo partita
radio amica ma se latino e me ne vado lì
distacco vai vai vai non mi scopriranno
mai principala di accesa quindi saranno
tutti sulla radio cosa ho fatto rega non
ci sto crescendo man con tutti gli
strati non mi cadono più vero non mi
pagate più il gargano italiano invece mi
pagano continuano cagarmi non gli frega
un cazzo della radio per fastidio sto
gioco è una roba indecente guam enti
team a crema ecco ragazzi concluso b
episodio grintoso ma tanto c'è da sei
comprendo che ha una roba che mi
mettesse così tanta ansia tipo outlast e
quindi ragazzi con questa bella
schermata poetica e questo puntino in
mezzo che non so che cosa cazzo sia
probabilmente la luce di gesù ci vediamo
non prese bisogna che cosa senti ragazzi
6 video è piaciuto lasciato momento mi
piace mi piace se metterete la crema
solare per non finire come quel luogo
che non era proprio bello però vabbè
servizi discreti e ci davano prossimo
vito le ragazze